Vienna the bridge between the barbaric
East and the civilised West my name is
Emma laser and let's get to it
settlements of people in and around
Vienna are known all the way back to the
Stone Age but there was no major human
establishment until the Iron Age when
the Celts created an opera Mon Leopold's
burg just north of today's Vienna city
centre since the kills were the first
that established themselves in and
around today's Vienna it is only natural
that the name Vienna is of Celtic origin
or is it Vienna's still today has
multiple names in multiple languages
with some of them sounding the same like
Vienna VN Vienna and some being
completely different like deny [ __ ]
[ __ ] and therefore their Tamala G of
the name just as in the Bratislava video
the first is depending on who you ask
because I don't have time to tell you
all the possible etymologies of the word
I'm going to go with the one that makes
the most sense to me the word Vienna is
most likely derived from a Roman Latin
name Vindobona which in turn is most
likely a latinized version of a Celtic
name meaning something like window
bright or fair white Bona village or
settlement this name could have referred
to some sort of a Celtic fort or could
have symbolized the entire oppidum
itself so the kids were doing their own
thing until the Romans captured the area
in 15 BC and in the first century
established a military camp for the 10th
Legion forming the site of today's
Vienna's city centre as it usually went
with the Roman military camps a town
grew up around it and was officially
raised to the status of a city / town in
the 3rd century it was also during the
Roman era that in Roman Emperor Marcus
Aurelius died in Vienna in the second
century while trying to annex Moravia
and Western Slovakia into the Empire
after that Vienna remained on the
outskirts of the Roman Empire making it
very susceptible to raids and invasions
especially after the decline of Rome and
the ensued migration period with the
political structure of the area gone as
Rome fell Vienna became sort of a
crossroads for many barbaric tribes from
the Germanic to the Slavic from the Huns
that of ours all came and went with
Vienna and during most likely due to
trade on the valuable Danube Ian trade
route between the Alps and the
Carpathians but perhaps one of the most
important moments for Vienna came during
the Hungarian evasion of Europe in the
late 9th and early 10th century during
this time the first mention of
quote-unquote Vienna occur
and the decisive win of Otto the first
against the invading Hungarian
solidified and secured Vienna under the
rule of not Slavic not Hungarian but
German rule throwing the victory the
Margraviate of Austria was created in
976 and given to the báb America family
for their loyalty to Otto first and Otto
second Vienna became the capital of the
province and 1155 and a year later
Austria was elevated to a Duchy the
Rowling family of babban Berks promoted
the buildup of Vienna as it continued to
be an important point of commerce on the
edge of the HRE
and the Danube e'en trade route at the
end of the 12th century during the end
of the Third Crusade Lilith v and Duke
of Austria arrested the King of England
Richard the Lionheart on some dubious
accounts and demanded ransom this came
in the form of 50,000 silver marks which
helped build up Vienna even more
including its first mint and formidable
medieval fortifications in the third
century Vienna received the HRE city
rights even though it technically
already received city rights during a
Roman period and also was granted the
rights of the staple port this meant
that any merchants traveling through
Vienna had to offer their goods for sale
in the city or face strict consequences
this main Vienna act as a middleman and
many century European trades and brought
lots of wealth into the city however in
the 1246 when the last babel burg duke
frederick ii died in battle austria with
vienna were left without the ruler but
no fear because the Czechs are here to
take over and promised to be super duper
nice rulers but of course we can have
Slavs ruling over Germans with their
backwater technology and completely
different culture so a small town to rid
of the first managed to get himself
elected as the king of the HRE
and subsequently used his newfound power
to take back the austrian lands and
establish himself as the first hop spur
ruler of austria but surprisingly in
vienna it took a long time for the
people to accept the hapsburgs as their
new rulers and partisans support for the
premise lit dynasty was strong going
into the 14th century the next century
Vienna continued to grow in parks shadow
but still expanding including the
foundation of the University of Vienna
and the began construction of the gothic
nave for the st. Stephen's Cathedral
going into the 15 and 16th century
Vienna started to emerge as one of the
most important cities in Europe it
became the seat of a bishop and hubs
now Emperor's sadly it was also during
this time that the Ottoman Turks were
pushing into the Habsburg lands links
teach to the Golden Apple on multiple
occasions power in 1683 during what was
to become the last Ottoman siege of
Vienna Austrian forces managed to defeat
the Ottomans with the help of the poet
this Battle of Vienna was major turning
point and Ottoman conquest and the
arguable start of the very slow down
fall of the Ottoman Empire but the
Habsburg lands now being reclaimed 18th
and 19th century are considered the
Golden Age of Vienna many palaces and
baroque buildings were built all around
the city and Vienna enjoyed the large
population growth but if you want to
make fancy buildings you're going to
need money and some semblance of
national stability and by 1740 Austria
was nearly fresh out of both if you want
to know how Austria held on tightly
enough to enjoy such nice things may I
entice you with the life and times of
Maria Teresa Austria's most famous arts
Duchess who didn't get her head lopped
off back to you sir after the end of her
reign the first factories in Vienna were
built in Leopold's debt this increased
construction the city was also
paralleled with the development of the
Viennese sewer system as Vienna was
trying to avoid the mistakes of other
major cities at the time during the
Napoleonic Wars Vienna was captured by
Napoleon on multiple occasions horridest
did not stop the Viennese expansion to
greatness after Napoleon's final defeat
the Congress of Vienna took place but
not very successfully as Nobles
preferred to indulge themselves and
lavish social events rather than figure
out the future state for Europe
nonetheless Vienna continued to expand
and modernize - all melt and walls of
the city were destroyed and replaced by
the rest as a monumental history's and
buildings were constructed on during
Strasser characterizing the architecture
of Vienna to this day
pipelines bringing fresh mountain water
to Vienna were constructed and the
danube started to be regulated due to
its unexpected flooding going into the
20th century Vienna enjoyed high
prosperity its population grew to the
record high of over two million
residents and the whole city was one of
the leading centres for culture arts
architecture music philosophy science
etc but the lavish lives of Austrian
nobility couldn't last forever and with
the rising wave of nationalism across
Europe the inevitable World War one
occurred expansion of Vienna sees does
all efforts were redirected towards
incapable austro-hungarian military
after World War one and the subsequent
breakup of the austro-hungarian Empire
Vienna ceased to exist as a leading
European metropolitan city in many
people's minds now the capital city of
the Republic of dojos derive urbanized
Vienna was very different compared to
the very ruler
of Austria this created many ideological
divides not just in Austria but in
Vienna itself militias of left and
right-wing parties were formed and then
ensued depression followed by the
bankruptcy of the largest Austrian bank
marked the way towards the Austrian
civil war Vienna with Austria was very
politically unstable
until when 1938 the annals of Austria
happened and Vienna became part of the
Third Reich anti-semitism was sadly well
received in Vienna and the many
high-ranking historical Jewish families
who lived in Vienna for centuries were
stripped of their human rights and most
of them did not survive till the end of
the World War two
Vienna itself was hated by Hitler who
wanted to build a blintz and turn Vienna
into a backwater City but this did not
happen as World War two came under way
during the war Vienna was heavily bombed
in the later half of the conflict and
many of its historical buildings had to
be painstakingly rebuilt after the war
it was also after the war that Vienna
along with Austria was divided between
the Allies just like Germany with Berlin
however Austria managed to sign the
Austrian state treaty declaring Austria
ever neutral and Foreign Affairs which
also give Austria with Vienna its
independence from the analyte occupation
chugging into the future Vienna enjoyed
a large economic boom with the rest of
Western Europe thanks in part due to the
Marshall Plan
the Vienna de mettre was constructed and
the third official seat of the United
Nations in Vienna was constructed as
well due to its neutrality Vienna has
about 17,000 diplomats living in the
city many assigned to international
organizations it is a city with a rich
past and a stunning present Vienna today
has been in the forefront of numerous
rankings ranging from most livable
cities to equality of living or
happiness surveys Vienna as a city is as
old as the continent of Europe itself a
city on the cutting edge of European
civilization throughout history and the
city which people like Beethoven Mozart
Schubert Strauss Freud and many more
notable figures that I could be naming
for days called home at some point it is
a city to rival them all and most
importantly it is a city whose airport
has free Wi-Fi
I hope you enjoyed the video I put lots
of work into it and I recommend re
watching it as there are lots of common
slash jokes all over the videos some
subtle it's not so much
oh so please go look at my friends jag
Rackham's video about mario theressa
he's great at making videos about
historical figures he never knew were
interesting and he definitely deserves
to be checked out also while you're
there please tell him his microphone is
eating his arm because i don't think he
has noticed if you want to see more
videos like this your subscription and
our support on patreon would be much
appreciated until next time Godspeed
[Music]